*cough* Oh geez hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to flix and chill two: Millennials now a while ago
I played a game called Netflix and chill
But then this game is a full release, actually a full sequel after the full release of that game
but I thought I'd skip to this one just to get something new in here because the other one was more in line with the
first game. Episode 1
Melanie. Hi Melanie! My name is Markiplier
I feel like we're gonna be hand-in-hand love and love like and like oh my God
I hope they're wearing masks.. oh
This is where you can definitely find me at the club getting it on wow Winn our first rave nevermind
I thought it was a club that's how far off I am. I know isn't it awesome! We really living the dream
Ok first order of business get some dick
Find Tristan and John oh we have to?
Fuck those guys come on
Winn do we have to can't we just let them find us?
I mean, we only met them the other day can we go and meet new people instead. Yeah, that's more like it
No way, we need to make sure we get to them before the other girls do come on
Alright, then let's find them uhhh
All right that them right there right next to you, whoa
it is hyped
- in here hello fellow young people are you up for the dancing?
I've been known to Boogie down every once in a while
Hello, hi there?
Hey, what's going on ladies?
Melanie what do you think what are you doing? Sorry my voice got really gruff for a second there. I like your hair
Thanks
Mel come on. Let's go sorry. She's not interested in whatever you're selling even though I like to jump dancing
That's pretty much my preferred method of dancing alright. Fine. God alright Jeez
Whatever your name is they can't even remember what my best friend's name is hello. Hi, how are you?, these's the right people?
It's me Melanie! Tristan, John!
Melanie
We're going to say each other's names endlessly. Hey ladies
We were wondering when you guys were gonna get here. Oh, please we always arrive fashionably late to the party
You guys having fun?
for sure!
Though would be more fun with a little bit of booze
You guys want to get some drinks before we do a bit of dancing. I mean we already got started
We're already Halfway through the Dance field maybe later on sure but nothing alcoholic
That's for me. Anything alcoholic. It will literally kill me can't do that sure but nothing alcoholic. I don't like
to drink in a rave
Well, I want something delicious sure I'll go grab something for us. hold on me and Melanie. We'll go grab something, won't we Mel?
sure someone need to keep you, Oh, okay? All right sure why not. I mean someone's got to keep you out of trouble
That's why I love you Mel. Let's go BFF's off to the bar
Hippity-Hoppity Whoopidy Whooo, all right, so
Why are we on over here?
Boy, howdy it is bumping in this club
Okay, never mind. It. Just stop bumping in the club. Hey there excuse me. We'd like
Stop what are you doing? I'm getting drinks. You don't buy drinks Melanie. You're a pretty girl
What are you talking about, didn't you just offer to get the guys drinks. I'm kind of confused right now
I'll take the guy on the left you the guy on the right. What are you talking about? Just follow my lead
We're not paying for any drinks tonight
All right, sure hey is that young me? hey handsome, oh hi? Hi there? Hello, thanks
Hey
Let's see, I'm-imma I'm gonna buy my own drinks
Why would I have someone else pay for my drinks? That's ridiculous?
excuse me bartender can I get a
oh
Melanie you won't believe the joke David just told me but it's funny but it's about let's plays
So what I didn't tell you something, did I?, I was just saying that i make YouTube gaming videos sometimes
lolol
It was a joke about let's plays, hahaha.
Stop it. You're too funny. Oh, who's your friend David?
He's cute. This is Graeme, my right-hand man!
Haha, hey sup. Hey, Graeme, have you met Melanie?
Hi there. Yeah, I'm Graeme nice to meet you. I don't need you. I have a boyfriend. I have a boyfriend
I have a boyfriend, good to meet you however Winnie, and I were just leaving
What are you talking about, David was just about to buy me a drink. Winnie...aphhhh
ugh, fine, Bartender. What can I get you?
I want a
Cranberry
soda
Just get a cranberry soda. Thanks actually we only have red punch, blue punch, or yellow punch. Oh, uh okay, I'll  take the red
Punch me red then and a blue for my friend John. Thanks :)
Here you go. Thanks a bunch. Hey before you go. I just want to say you have a really cute smile. Oh
Thanks. It's not coming on to you, sweetie. Don't worry
I just on the lookout for a model for my blog, and you're like super pretty you'd be interested in helping out
That sounds really sketchy
for your blog aheee
You need a model
I'm gonna go with no. I'm gonna hard pass on that one. I'm sorry now really. It's cool. No worries enjoy the drinks. Alright, see you around
Okay, we'll be right back. Gonna go see our friend real quick, let's go Mel. Winnie is a meanie pooh
Winnie
What are you doing? Sashaying your hips like that? That was a blast! I don't know
I don't really feel like taking advantage of people like that. Oh, please we're doing those guys a favor
They'll feel is more confident now that some girls approached them
I'd have a great time because of it uh uh
I don't know Winnie. uh oh quit your whining and let's dance live let's Dance ah
Yeah, okay
Okay, uh I'm a dancing that we can huh yeah good to get whiplash
Oh, yeah, ow ow
Well that was some fun dancing you millennials might what the f do you think you're doing?
We're talking about this mate. I'm dancing with melody whinnies your girl
Hey, what's your there's dancing where I'm dancing don't be an arse
Ain't being an arse you're being an arse well, then why don't we let her decide herself sounds good to me come?
Melanie do you want to be?
Pissed with him. I will done. No. I don't remember who's
remember who you know I'm good with dancing by myself and not being bartered for
this neither
Sorry, I think I must go sit this one out. Why don't you two dance together for a while settle your differences?
Thank you. Fella Melanie. I think we all need a break. I'm going to dance over there for a while pieces
Why are they good clean me? All right goodbye?
See you around is weird
Go over here. Huh? Hey how's it going? Hell? Oh
Yeah, you like to Dance now Melanie dance me. I'm trying
sure, let's do it of course right by the speaker so we can go down a
Meld is so much fun. See we don't need no stinky boys. Have a good time. That's what I was saying from the beginning
Literally the first thing I said
totally right hell yeah, we can that Puttan just us girls ah
you gotta
Sister, you know Melon either something about you. You make me feel good
Well, what do you mean? I mean, I feel good around you don't you feel it do not?
Really, it's about a lot of uncomfortable
what I mean
Yeah, yeah, you know feel - you make me feel like anything's possible you're so much fun. Oh come on. You're making me blush now
Dance further away. Oh you're great the star finger gun owners you backup. All right
Let's go back to meet up with the group. Yeah, you're right those bullies probably don't know what to do without us right now
Alright boy. They are angrily
dancing hey you boys, uh
You boys all right over here your boys. All right. How you doing boys
Melanie come on
There we go all friends totally platonic. No need for emotions. That's what the hell
John
Where we go?
Now whoa careful careful mel. I thought I saw time slowed down per second
You that was a close one? Thanks, John you can let go of me now
You can let go me now. Oh. Yeah. Sorry glad you're okay
Okay, look
She's what was that about yeah? What's her deal? Go see? What's the matter?
Some emotional dynamics. I was now ready for I'll go see what's the matter see you guys have a go dance over this way
See was wrong with Melanie
Hey mel. How's it going?
Hey win, what's up? Oh, you're winning. I'm melanie
I'm Winnie you're mel. I'm your winnie. I'm melanie. Oh you mean, what's up. You know fully well with them
I really don't winnie. I thought you were melanie's hold hot
Did I do something wrong? No? I didn't do I fell do you need did you need to get drunk is this about Tristan?
Is about Tristan how could you tell they're so tired of giving them them giving you all the attention. I mean aren't I cute too?
Let's see no no
See the way, you're gorgeous. You're gorgeous
Are you serious winnie you're gorgeous?
Ha ha la la la you're just saying that I mean it. I mean it of course. I mean it winning
You're my most beautiful friend by a long shot
You're right. I am beautiful, and I don't need any stupid guide and tell me anything else. Yeah, that's the spirit Winnie
I think I'm on the dance by myself for a while
You know that's a mean time away from these jerks feel free to come meet up with me if you want. Thanks, Melanie, huh?
You get it winnie who is no longer melanie? Who are all these people here. I wish I could jump like you. Oh boy
I am having fun boo doo doo Doodoo Doodoo walking out the front door don't eat any of this bull
I'm gonna. Go away now. Oh, what is happening?
What's the deal here get drink instead of dancing?
Hey Bartender. Have some more red punch. Thanks
Okay, Gonna awkwardly stare for a bit. Oh
I
Don't need nobody to tell me how to have a good time ended up alone by the end of it
But I'm realizing. I don't mind being alone hashtag independent look at all the likes
Look at all those likes oh
Yeah, get it girl. Yeah. Winnie what you are with know your wings you are always winning. I'm melanie. Haha
Take some of that oh, silly. I liked it them that was fun
I don't know. How many episodes there are this is one is melanie absolute two is frank alright. So anyway
There's more episodes to this. I don't think it's a very long game
So maybe I could play another episode if you guys want to see it that was entertaining
Just a lot of possible options there some of them. I don't know just rubbed me the wrong way
Which is why just coasted by don't need no boys. Don't need no girls don't need no alcohol
Just need me and then I have a good time by myself
That's nice
So thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you thought if you want to see more let me know down in
The comments as well and as always. I will see you in the next video, buh-bye!